well we broke 100 degrees again today
and it could get even hotter in the next
few days Templar endo has a full look at
our forecast tonight yeah it looks like
Thursday seems to be our hottest day and
that's the reason for the excessive heat
warning issued specifically for that day
only for the Las Vegas Valley and of
course prompt and mesquite however those
of you down the Colorado River Laflin
searchlight those areas of the lake as
well that heat warning begins as early
as Wednesday at 11:00 a.m. until
Thursday at 8:00 p.m. with good reason
temperatures will be way above average
and again will be approaching near
record Heat 91 right now in Summerlin 98
for Aliante 97 for you up there in Sky
Canyon 97 for the lakes 100 even for
downtown along with Nellis 101 sunrise
mountain and same story for you in Green
Valley and Whitney ranch 100% for
henderson and Blue Diamond just under
the century mark for those of you also
in mountains the edge in also Southern
Highlands 96 Seven Hills and anthem - 97
for prop 102 for Mesquite hot out there
in Death Valley coming in at 108 degrees
104 for those of you joining us down
river and Laughlin right now a lot of
eight news now view was there clouds
galore outside right now some echoes
coming back on the mountains but really
this is not touching the ground it's
just too dry very dried the surface low
dew points low humidity but that's some
high level moisture however this low
that's been sort of sitting and spitting
here off the coast will stick around for
a few days out here and then eventually
make its way on shore in the meantime
it's pumping in there
those clouds that we're seeing overhead
and that's the reason also why we're
getting some of the hotter temperatures
we got that off the coast we've got some
ridging to the east that ridging really
is responsible for all this heat 104 for
tomorrow 107 for Thursday the reason I'm
showing you these numbers is because
these are the records so we'll come very
close to the records
I don't think we'll reach them
officially but will come very close to
it numbers will drop on Friday with that
lower pin pointed out to you as it makes
its way on shore
here's what's going to happen we're
gonna see winds increase I'm gonna see
these numbers drop to 90 on Saturday and
Sunday below average and 88 Hyundai
for next Hui here's your forecast 79
degrees by morning thick clouds morning
sprinkles and isolated sprinkles are
still possible in the morning
southwest winds about 5 to 10 Kirsten
loves this graphic this is our special
for Wednesday 104 degrees hot and partly
cloudy this is the vent day right no no
this is the grande mentok veinte is the
big one so this is the venting this is
what Kirsten gets that one right there
just looking good good flora cast high
sort of all 101 for seven low 103 for
North Las Vegas hundred six sunrise
mountain green valley same story for you
102 for prompt Boulder City 102 as well
Rocklin at 112 so here's your extended
forecast for the next couple of days
here big heat through Thursday that heat
warning goes into effect Thursday like
we said in the Las Vegas Valley chances
for showers possibly maybe some storms
later on on Friday evening maybe
Saturday morning and then there's that
number drop along with more wind
expected for next week we'll have
another weather update coming up just
about half an hour away and meet Alice
Center back to you